Hahahaha.
Screen's off center.
Oops.
My bad.
What?
Professional Vtuber, what are you talking about?
I'm Indie.
Duh.
Welcome home, Master.
Welcome.
Still get paid.
You get paid, don't you?
What if I...
Spend all the money I make?
What if I make money, but then I spend it all?
What if it's a net profit of zero?
She's cute again today.
What are you talking about?
I'm not cute.
But this is how I sound.
Orochi is irresponsible with her income.
Sounds like a doki situation.
I mean...
That's just way too much fun.
Spending money.
Oh my gosh, I was thinking about that today.
I was just like...
You know...
What would they do about my taxes?
If I made a bunch of money, but then I invested all the money back...
Into my streams.
Because I was like, oh gosh.
Okay, I had to...
Okay.
What if you spend all your money, just like me for real?
No!
Nexie!
Nexie, you literally... I saw you.
You literally sent an akasupa to doki last night.
Your money, please.
Hi, ghost lady.
Hi, Squidward.
Chat does reflect streamer.
Yeah, it's a business expense, Mr. Irisman.
I...
I was thinking about it because...
Okay.
I still have things to pay for.
Not everything is done for my debut.
I still have to pay two whole teams of people.
I paid...
You guys, I think my...
I think the rigging might be done today.
Oh...
Beast Wars Megatron was one of my first toys as a kid.
It's cool, but thoughts about...
No, sorry.
Beast Wars Megatron is my favorite.
But I also like to say Waspinator.
But it was worth it.
But your wallet!
Hayden, thank you for the 5 gifted!
You'll be next!
Welcome back for 6 months.
Thank you and Prince of Belka.
Welcome back!
Oh my gosh.
Belka.
The phantom income.
So I was like...
I was like, if I just like spend all my money...
On other things...
Then...
What would they do if they're just like...
If I'm like, hey, tax people, I have no money.
To give you money.
Because I spent it all on my business.
It's basically like a net profit of zero.
You know?
I'm not making any money.
It all goes back.
Consult an accountant.
No!
I have an accountant, don't worry.
Spoopy time.
Spoopy time!
It's like recycling.
Yeah!
It's like recycling!
Look, my money is going to a cute ghost now.
Oops.
No!
Guys, I got like a new moisturizer.
For my ectoplasm.
And I don't think it works well with my...
With my... With me.
Actually, my face is burning.
And it has been all day.
Are you moist?
No!
I think maybe I'm having an allergic reaction.
I don't know.
Isn't that spooky?
Akira!
I went... I did like a face treatment recently.
They were like, you should use this moisturizer after it.
And I was like, okay.
I don't like the moisturizer.
It's not good.
Your honor, I assure you this $3000 spent on Metal Gear Merch is instrumental to my business.
If I show it on stream, it's a business expense.
Akira!
Welcome to the membership.
Thank you!
Anyways guys, welcome to...
Or welcome back, if you watched the first part.
Spooky's Jump Scare Mansion.
We played the main game.
We played the mansion some time ago.
So we should spend our money to get a net profit of 0 too.
Um...
Did you hear about the Over the Garden Wall concert on the 29th?
Yeah, I did.
I did hear about it.
Do you know why I trust trumpet players despite them always betraying me?
I'm willing to give them the benefit of the doot.
6 out of 10.
Dang, tough crowd.
Tough crowd.
Like a Jolly Rancher.
That don't impress me much.
Or rather the audience.
Anyway, like I said, we did the mansion.
So today we'll be doing Calamari Hospital and the Spooky's Dollhouse.
I think I did it the wrong order in the title.
My bad.
We will do it.
I like originally thought for some reason that these were like the longest ever.
I had blocked out like a ton of time initially.
I was like, oh, I think these are like 6 hours or something.
And then I was like, I tried to look it up on... I usually look up games on like...
What's it called?
How long to beat?
And then I add... I take the average and then I add like 2 or 3 hours to them.
And so I was just like... But the how long to beat only showed the full game.
So I was like...
I can't tell.
So then I looked it up on YouTube.
Because I was like, like I said, I was going to play this on Saturday and block out like...
I was like, oh my gosh, I'm going to do this and Devil May Cry, like 2 endurance streams.
I'm so spooky crazy.
But I looked it up and it was like 45 minutes.
I don't know how long the dollhouse one is.
But we finally get to know the story of the Spooky's Jumpscare Mansion.
So that's kind of cool.
Take Minto Paisen account.
Yeah, the times that I go to the bathroom.
The times that I talk.
And the times that I lose.
Dollhouse is longer, but it's still less than 2 hours.
So 45 minutes plus 2 hours, yeah.
We should be good.
Sorry again also, if you're watching the VOD, this probably doesn't mean much to you.
Unless you couldn't make it because I had to change the time.
I'm so sorry, something came up tonight that I was like...
I've got to make time for this.
So I apologize that I had to move it back.
I'm so sorry.
VOD watcher here.
I'm watching the VOD right now.
It's okay.
What do you mean okay?
Write to your streamer driver.
Your struber driver.
5 stars, please.
If I were an Uber driver, I would have nice...
Well, my car is not very nice.
But I would have the nice amenities.
I would have the charging cables.
And I would have the snacks.
Or little bottles of water.
I would have all of that.
Then you would rate me 5 stars.
3 out of 5, she hates us.
3 stars, talk during the trip.
Is that why...
Oh my gosh, there's probably people that actually are just like...
Gosh, I can't stand watching VTubers play games because they just talk through it.
Or their big heads take up a whole chunk of the screen.
VOD watchers, rewind 3 hours.
Thanks for the perk!
2016, the developer received a cease and desist letter from the company Spooky House Studios...
...who claimed the title Spooky's House of Jumpscares infringed on their trademark.
The game was renamed to Spooky's Jumpscare Mansion.
What?
That's so stinky.
Spooky House... What?
And of course you're gonna change it because a small indie dev is not gonna be able to afford a big lawyer...
...against a big company.
Stinky, stinky, stinky, stinky, stinky.
Really stinky.
Monster Energy tried suing a bunch of games that use the word monster.
Oh my gosh!
Yeah, PU.
We hate that.
That's why they changed the name.
I thought it was because it came out as 1.0.
I don't know.
Did you know this game was originally going to be Resident Evil 5?
Crazy!
Anyway, so I guess we start with Calamari Hospital.
Unlock the secrets of this strange abandoned hospital.
Let's get started!
Oh my gosh, this feels so familiar.
Every day is Wednesday.
We're on room...
...995.
Oh.
Flashing lights warning maybe?
Oh my goodness.
Is this guy gonna come?
I guess I'll turn the audio up a little bit.
I think last time I played this people said that the audio was too low.
They were like, I can't hear anything.
So you guys get all the jump scares too.
Here we go.
We're in the hospital.
Surely in a place.
I wouldn't say hospital.
Oh my gosh.
I still have my axe.
I wouldn't say hospital, but...
I've got the stream muted.
No hiding in the comments VOD watchers.
I see you scrolling down there trying to avoid...
Also, this doesn't have any rooms written.
You're just like, scary game.
I better hide in the comments so nothing sees me.
I forgot I have stamina.
Alright.
Spooky!
Thanks!
She is really... Hold on.
I'm gonna actually try turning up the...
I have the volume low, that's why.
Maybe like that.
That should be better.
Apply.
I love the Chilby Jam.
That should be better, I think.
Let me know if it's still too low though.
So is this just exactly like the original?
Like Spooky is just in a hospital this time.
Welcome to Karamari Hospital.
Oh no, it's way different.
Drinking fountain.
Oh, it's a save!
How?
Like Silent Hill of them.
We can go in there.
We can go in here.
Why is it so foggy?
It really is Silent Hill.
Let's go to the bathroom.
Wow, it's really big.
This is discrimination!
We can only go to the men's bathroom.
Guys?
That doesn't seem so good.
This one is out of order.
Wow, the urinals are pink!
Wow, it's so cute!
Oh my gosh, I didn't know the men's bathroom was so cute.
It's broken.
I'm not gonna be like the guy in Silent Hill who sticks his hand down there.
Gosh, what's his name?
I can't remember.
That's why I died.
It all happened the day you became world wife.
I wanted to rebrand but YouTube won't let me add the sparkle of Hiroshi Mark.
Why are we rebranding?
But thank you.
Oh James!
I keep wanting to say something else.
Like Jack.
I knew it started with a J.
So this one we can't go in.
It looks like there might be something in there though.
You see?
Oh, it's a little bloody.
And also pink.
Oh my god, everything is pink.
It's too cute.
I'm a big fan.
James... James...
Stop peeking.
If anybody is living outside of the United States, this is like so real.
You know how I could literally just peek in to this and see the whole toilet seat?
This is it.
This is real.
This is how like actual... sometimes the holes are even bigger.
This is the horror.
I could be like hey, anybody in there?
It's so awful.
Horrible, horrible, horrible.
Oh this is locked.
So this is already way different.
Oh my goodness.
Okay, it's spooky now.
I was gonna say I really like the music.
Is that a safe area perhaps?
The words never forget.
Oh, the woods never forget.
Neither should you.
Broken?
Okay.
Joint pain?
I can't read.
How can anybody see from that tiny TV from all the way over there?
Hello.
Broken.
Okay.
Oh.
Dr. Hamada, Oncologist.
The patient has displayed increased depression after being informed of their terminal disease.
Yeah, I would think so.
I prescribed an antidepressant to regulate this, but was later told that I had cancelled the prescription.
I have no memory of cancelling the meds, nor can I find any evidence that my orders were tampered with.
Hall.
Rat room.
Stairs up.
Lots of patient rooms.
Oh, what is this?
Don't bother the doctors.
They've got enough blood on their hands.
Deal with it yourself.
Alright.
I can't tell like what is our goal here right now.
You guys know that back rooms game?
Oh, wait.
No, sorry.
That's incorrect.
It's like a...
It's like...
One of many... Which one?
I know, that's why I was like, wait a second.
No, it's like...
It's a... I can't remember the name of it.
It's giving me this vibe though.
Oh, we can go upstairs.
Oh, or downstairs?
Content warning?
It's electronically sealed.
OK, so we gotta come back here.
I can't remember, but it starts here.
It starts in a school and then you go to like a library and then you go to...
I think the latest chapter was like...
Then you go to like an underground sewer.
The classrooms!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
The classrooms.
My fiancé is a huge fan and a shy wisp.
His birthday was last week.
Wanted to know if you wish him a happy belated...
Happy belated in honor of Spooky Month.
Of course!
Wait, he didn't say his name though.
I'll just say Hime's fiancé.
Oh, I wasn't there.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday Hime's fiancé.
Happy birthday!
Alright, let's go downstairs.
Downstairs.
Definitely a different atmosphere here.
Are we gonna get jumpscared?
Maintenance room?
Broken, broken.
Break room.
If I grab this...
Take the key.
What will happen if I take the key?
Anybody wanna fizz?
Because spooky...
What am I reading?
Nurse Tanaka, report number 404.
It seems we are losing patients due to surgical complications much more often than normal.
What have the doctors been doing?
Half of these procedures seem completely unnecessary.
I know the doctors and surgeons are above me and probably know many things I don't.
But this is getting strange.
Guys, it's getting really spooky right now.
Office key.
I don't think we saw an office.
We saw a maintenance room.
Locked.
All of these were locked too.
Yeah, broken.
Broken.
OK?
Living core, thanks for the gift.
Dead.
Are you sleeping?
Can I crawl under you?
Wait, the music stopped.
Safe area.
We are fine.
Oops, we nicked an artery.
So, to an office.
There was one key over here that maybe...
Safe room.
Masashi, welcome back.
Angel, thanks for the gifted.
I unironically wish that there was an IRL place that was fogged out like Silent Hill 24-7.
I mean, to each their own.
Right.
Oh wait, read?
No?
Oh, read.
Dr. Hamada, Oncologist.
Seems the other me has been giving him large doses of hallucinogenics.
What?
It's called London.
London.
Yeah, just go there.
They have worsened the depression and he is now constantly screaming and expressing terror at seemingly random intervals.
I've tried using a dialysis machine to remove some of the drugs, but it seems futile.
Can we go on the computer?
I love this decor.
Very interesting.
Broken.
Oh my gosh!
A little baby.
It looks just like you guys right before stream.
What's this?
It looks like something goes here.
Broken.
Remember, wash your hands.
Work hard and have a nice day.
Wow, this could be my desk someday you guys.
Oh, sorry.
I wonder if I can.
Maintenance key.
Oh, I wonder if I could have chopped that guy up now that I think about it.
Dr. Tochigi.
Hepatologist.
What's hepatologist?
Is that dealing with blood?
I was just informed that the procedure to extract the patient's liver became fatal.
Doctor, my bobble mint is missing its spring.
Liver.
Oh.
I don't know why.
Why did we take his liver?
There are no donation requests and he was showing signs of improvement.
Oh my god.
The surgical staff told me I personally demanded the liver be removed for an emergency transplant.
And the worst thing is I found it.
I found his liver.
His entire liver.
Just sitting on my desk.
Well, where is it?
Uh oh.
Exit?
Deformity wing.
Electronically sealed.
Do you think we can just leave or is that just giving us false hope?
It looks fake.
The door?
Locked.
Alright, well let's go to the maintenance room.
Bye chill area.
It's been nice knowing you.
Time to go back into the horror basement.
Do you think I can chop that guy?
Here, I'm gonna try it real quick.
It's not killing me.
Dang.
He's tough.
Maintenance right here.
What am I doing this for?
Why am I doing this though?
Today is my birthday so I was wondering if I can get a happy birthday from my favorite freaky mint ghost.
I'm also celebrating by going to a Chicago otake meetup and the round one hololive collab.
Oh my gosh Sora Ichi!
That sounds so fun!
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday Sora Ichi.
Ok guys, it's time to be brave.
I'm gonna press it and I'm gonna be scared probably.
I think we need to go.
Why is it red?
Why did we do that?
I think we're stupid.
Broken.
Oh no!
We're in the...oh no.
We're in like the fatal frame part of the...oh my god!
How is this on?
Who's we?
This is a collective effort.
What are you talking about?
Everything I do, you guys do too.
The scoliosis.
That doesn't look very...
What big hands you have.
Is he gonna hug me?
Abandoned hospital is a little too relaxing.
Let's sabotage the power.
If I attack him first...
Aiya!
Stairs.
Upwards or downwards?
Who knows?
If I walk in front of him...
Oh gosh.
I don't think this is a good place to be in.
Let's...
Wow, even the decor matches everything.
They're like, what about a tree?
But make it red.
And then a chair that stares at the door.
Isn't that sca...
Sit!
I can sit?
What do you guys see when you see this?
This is one of those blot tests.
What do you see?
A bat?
A butterfly?
A fairy?
I see.
A brain?
No.
See, you're seeing what you wish you had.
This is a test of your truest desires.
A luchador.
Did you want to be a luchador when you were a kid?
I want to be a wrestler?
I guess so.
I didn't save.
Let's...
Go save real quick.
Oh my god.
That guy is so scary.
Is this area bad now too?
What about the safe room?
That had, you know...
The lights on and everything.
Even our happy room.
I wonder if anything changed in the bathroom.
Oh gosh.
Oh, ok.
Nope.
Still pink.
That wasn't on before.
Oh my god.
Wait, I seriously walked right past here and that wasn't on.
Ishmael says keep your head down.
Thanks for keeping me company on my lunch break.
It wasn't on though, right?
Back to this spooky area.
Nevermind.
I think...
Why
was he there?
Oh, he's gone.
Oh, he's actually gone.
I don't know if I want to go down this way instead.
Let's just go into some other rooms and...
Oh my god.
I hear him though.
He doesn't walk in the rooms, right?
Why is he down?
Is it because I saved?
Oh gosh.
This DLC is too spooky you guys.
It's broken.
Oh, this is the sitting room.
Ok, let's try it.
Oh, sit.
Uh oh.
What's going to happen?
I
can just chill in here.
My vision is getting a little hazy.
My head can do a 360.
Woah, is this mess... I don't think this would mess up the bit, right?
Woah, it's getting a little snowy.
What's going on?
Is this supposed to do anything?
It's kind of relaxing actually.
It's kind of nice.
It's kind of putting me to sleep.
It's kind of great.
Ok, count the pixels.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14, 15, 16, 17.
Actually, it's not getting any darker.
That's a new development.
Anything else new?
This guy is still outside the door.
It's a really clean bloodline.
What was that?
Should I get up?
What if I turn around?
Are you still there?
You saved, it's fine.
I can't see you if you're all the way up there.
Are you going to do anything, mister?
Are you going to do anything?
Oh, he's showing up more often now.
This is my nice relaxing...oh, he's really close.
Oh, it's getting darker.
Guys, it's getting dark.
No way, the fuzz.
I'm looking
around, but I see nothing.
Darkness.
Hmm.
Death by JPEG?
Are we about to die?
No.
What if I stood up right now?
I can still hear the guy outside the door.
That guy is really throwing off our vibes.
I'm literally falling asleep right now.
Out of body experience?
We made a copy?
Astral projection?
Am I a ghost?
I can't tell.
It's me.
Damn, I'm hot.
No, these aren't any different.
I don't think anything else changed except this.
So, I guess...
I don't hear that guy.
I think we're ok.
Oh, note.
Dr. Kanagawa Hematologist.
The patient did not recover from the blood loss.
I feel like there is a monster inside my head and it's pushing me away while it works on something.
I wake up in the patient's room standing over him while an arterial catheter was in the patient.
Letting him just bleed out onto the floor.
Oh, so hematologist.
What was the other one?
Hepatologist, right?
Ah, ok.
Because I was thinking hemoglobin.
I was getting it wrong.
You know, they're similar.
I'm not a doctor.
I don't need to know.
Oh my gosh, but what if I went to a hepatologist and I was like...
Excuse me, I need help with my blood.
They're like, I got you.
I think he's right outside the door.
Where else did I need to go?
Oh, this is the bathroom.
Ok, don't go in there.
We could go downstairs.
We could...
Since we made that astral projection, I'm going to save because...
I really don't want to sit in the chair again.
Since it took a second.
There was one door at the very end and then there was downstairs.
So maybe we go downstairs, perhaps.
We'll see where the guy is.
He is down there.
Oh gosh.
I don't like it.
Oh, we're on the other side.
We're on the other side.
The morgue.
I'm just gonna...Oh, the morgue is really big.
Oh, the morgue is very big.
Isolation room?
Dang it.
So one place I want to go.
Oops, all morgue.
Oh, this is way scarier than I thought it was going to be.
Oh guys, it's DLC.
After I read this they are all going to lift up, aren't they?
Nurse Tanaka, report number 406.
Something sinister is beating on the wall of my subconscious.
Beating like a war drum, motioning me to march down into hell.
OK, we're fine.
Something is laughing.
I don't like this.
OK, so it's one big room.
I got acid?
Metal gear?
I don't think there was anything else.
I'm checking.
OK.
Alright.
What do you mean?
Oh, it's this part.
What does that mean?
I'm scared.
What do you mean by that?
OK, we only have one door here.
Oh shoot.
The medallion.
I know where this goes.
OK, once I get it I think we're going to have to sprint to the other door.
Oh shoot.
Nevermind, the door doesn't open.
OK.
Hello.
Gosh!
Oh no.
Oh my god, I'm stuck.
I'm stuck.
Do I have to kill you?
I'm dead.
Your soul wanders an endless maze.
No!
Well now I know what's down here.
OK, hopefully this guy is not here.
No!
OK, let's give him like one minute.
A three, a two.
Perfect.
Alright, let's go into this room first.
I don't know if I have to pick up the notes each time.
Alright, we got some acid.
Oh, OK, OK.
Oh gosh, what do I do with this guy though?
Do I just attack him?
Do I axe him?
Do I axe him a question?
A question?
Just run?
It wouldn't let me run though.
Like I got stuck on...I think I got stuck on a wall.
Maybe I didn't though.
Oh my gosh.
You can run past, but you got stuck on a body.
OK.
No, see?
It's not letting me go.
You guys, it's not letting me go.
Oh, I have unlimited stamina here, which is kinda nice.
OK.
Oh my gosh.
Door!
We made it!
We made it.
Yippee!
They wouldn't do a jump scare in the stairs, because that's where you could fall and die.
Save time.
Sorry, gonna save scum a little wee bit.
Can you acid the meat wall?
Oh, that's a good...
Oh!
Yeah.
Recruit?
OK.
Thanks Spooky.
She's so...
She's so optimistic.
It was this one, right?
Yeah.
Medallion!
You think Spooky knows people are legit dying?
Yeah, I think she does, actually.
Let's not do that real quick.
Let's...
Wait a second.
Since all these doors are... I'm assuming all these doors are open?
Like... Well, this one was locked.
This one was fake.
But this one was...
Yeah.
We are in here now.
But what is here?
We are in area.
We are...
Oh, I hear him again.
Broken.
Are we just on the other side?
Maybe?
I wonder.
Is the fog getting thicker?
It might be.
I want to try putting the acid on that monster thing and see if it works.
I think it's a loop.
Quite possibly.
You're correct.
It might be that we've done everything we can right now.
Acid!
Oh!
It did work!
So now...
Besides that one room...
That...
Yeah, we got a shortcut.
Besides the one room that seemed pretty evil...
And that, like, as soon as I walk in, it seems pretty evil.
I think...
I think we're good to continue.
I think.
Am I hearing more TVs?
I feel like...
Alright.
Let's go back.
Let's go into...
Let's go into the secret tunnel!
I'm so scared you guys.
I feel like I'm not talking much because I'm just so scared.
I'm scared.
What's that?
That's not a noise that I really like.
Oh my god.
Oh no.
There's just body... There's just little parts.
Little pieces.
Oh my god.
This sounds very...
Like PT.
Oh gosh.
Free organs!
Yippee!
Oh what's that?
Oh my gosh.
Who needs a new pair of lungs?
And what about this?
Oh this one is wriggling.
This one is fresh everybody!
Oh I really don't like this at all.
Guys, I really don't like this.
Oh my gosh.
I really don't like this.
I want this to end so bad right now.
Oh gosh.
Oh stinky.
I want this to end so bad right now.
I'm so scared.
Touch?
Ok hold on.
This seems a little bit big.
I wonder if you think these are a loop.
Oh baby!
Oh it's a baby!
Ok.
I guess we better touch it.
It feels cold.
What is it though?
I feel like I haven't learned anything.
You know?
I feel like I'm supposed to be learning stuff about what's going on in this jumpscare mansion everything and...
learning about lore and why this is all happening.
Place Sunshine Academy.
Here at Sunshine Academy, love is in the air.
You have transferred from your high school in the States and cannot wait to take your new classes here at school.
Who knows, maybe your true dreams will come to fruition within these red halls.
Your mother has packed you a lunch.
Day 1.
Oh ok, that's part of the game.
I thought somebody was behind me.
Oh god, Shine!
Hello there, you must be the new transfer student from America.
How do you like it here so far?
It's ok, I guess.
Oh my gosh.
There's a lot of cute girls here.
I miss my home.
Yeah, she's very cute.
I'll say there's a lot of cute girls here.
Oh please, well don't worry, it's sure to get better.
We have the illusion of choice everybody.
Oh her name is...
Oh by the way, my name is Ume.
Ume.
I can't read this font at all.
What?
Ito?
Ume Ito?
School bell.
Oh that's the bell.
I gotta talk to you later.
Oh hi, have you started liking this school yet?
A horror game and a dating sim?
It'll never work.
What do you mean?
I wanted to see the rest.
Class was interesting.
This place is starting to grow...to grow me.
It's starting to grow me!
Glad to hear it.
To tell the truth, I had doubts when I first came here too.
My dad lost his job and we had to move here and stay with my grandparents.
I'm sorry.
At least you see...oh that's a sad story.
At least you see your grandparents a lot.
Glad to hear it.
It wasn't all bad.
And after a while I learned how to enjoy myself here.
Well, see you tomorrow.
Day 2.
I don't like the sound it makes.
So how was your second day?
If you're wondering, I turned the volume down quite a bit.
So hopefully it's not...if you're just like the BGM got really low, that's why.
Have things gotten better yet?
Everything is disgusting here.
I think it's going to be fun.
What are these options?
Are we...no see...
We should have played it cool from day 1.
Cool and mysterious.
You know, we talked to her.
We can't just ignore her now.
Oh sorry, it's heart, heart, heart.
Let's do heart, heart, heart.
Well, OK.
Anyway, today is a new day and full of new experiences.
Oh she's sad!
You guys!
Elris!
The flies are...
Can't fit anymore.
I can't wait.
Dot, dot, dot.
I'm a terrible boyfriend.
What are you talking about?
We met this girl yesterday!
The flies...
The class was at least interesting today.
I had no idea how many perfect spirals existed in nature.
Uzumaki, Uzumaki, Uzumaki.
You're a perfect flirt!
I thought it was boring.
I've known a lot...You guys, we have to flirt.
Why didn't she respond?
Oh hey, do you live down this road too?
Do you live down this road?
No, I'm just...
I do indeed.
I'm going to close my eyes and pick whichever one I land on.
Oh, I guess I do.
Why does she look so sad though?
Well, I live right down there at the second house on the left.
Why does she look so sad about that?
It's an old house, but it's the place I call home.
My home is inside you.
Wait, it's like my whole body is trying to peel apart on the inside.
Wait, it's two different sentences, but...
My
home is inside you.
Wait, this is like...I just...Wait.
He means her heart, right?
He means like inside your heart, right?
No response again.
She is turning down all my flirting, all my advances.
Oh my god, my girlfriend is a little shy.
Hey, what's the matter?
So slippery, drippy, splashy.
Are you feeling alright?
This is day three of Metal Gear Brain rot.
What?
So slippery, drippy, splashy.
I like how well your skin pulls across your skull.
Flirts?
What if this isn't a dream?
A fog, a lost memory of a something.
I can't read it.
Guys, everybody should be using this line.
I like how well your skin pulls across your skull.
Flirt!
I'm just going to flirt.
Don't be like that, baby.
What's wrong?
All your water is leaking.
Those eyes shine like a house fire.
Flirt.
I can still look around the room, I just realized.
I was so into the game, I completely forgot I was in the BO area.
Don't be like that, baby.
You are in hell.
I mean, I did leave heaven.
I am yours now.
Our flirting worked, guys!
Are you happy now?
You wanted me to talk, didn't you?
She's disappearing.
Wait, our meds!
This is just a dream.
No, Ume!
Ume, no!
You wanted me to talk, didn't you?
I am yours now.
You are in hell.
This is what you wanted?
You are marked?
I am yours now.
That place isn't for you.
You are in hell.
No!
You guys, stop!
We have to stop taking our meds!
Are you happy now?
Now I'm yours.
You wanted me to talk, didn't you?
I'll always love you.
Is this what you wanted?
Are you happy now?
Don't you know?
Now I'm yours.
Is this what you wanted?
Don't you know?
I think she's choking.
You are in hell.
Sick beat.
She's turning into a ghost.
We're into that here.
This is just a dream.
Murderer!
I didn't do that!
You are marked.
I am yours now.
What is wrong?
This place isn't for you.
How long do I go until it's over?
Your blood is soaking through your eyes.
OK, get out of here, Ume.
Is this all you are going to talk about?
Don't you know?
Yeah, she's almost gone.
She's quite the yapper, isn't she?
Why?
Oh.
I'll always love you.
This is like one of those Magic 8 Balls.
You ask it a question.
Let's see.
What should we ask?
Ume-chan, will I find love?
You are marked.
Ume-chan.
Ah...
Oh, what...
It has to be a yes or no question.
Are you OK?
I am yours now.
It's so...
The sound effect is so small.
Can I get out of this?
I don't even know.
I feel like I have to go until the end.
Just kind of like with the chair.
I can barely hear it.
She's almost gone.
Do you really think this is real?
Sometimes she says something a little bit different.
So I'm trying not to rush through it too fast.
I can't even see her anymore.
Do you really think this is real?
What is wrong?
This is just a dream?
Now I'm yours.
Oh my god, no.
Please, no more choke.
It takes so long.
I can still hear it.
Can you guys...
I don't know.
Do you guys hear it?
This is just a dream.
Please, no more choke.
Why?
What is wrong?
Murderer.
You are in hell.
I can still barely, barely hear it.
Now I can't hear it anymore.
Oh my god, the choke.
What do I do?
It's like actually gone.
You can hear it?
I'm scared to look around.
Yeah, very faint.
Really.
I'm going to look around.
Oh god.
I feel like I missed out on something.
Second playthrough.
God,
how annoying she is.
Isabelle, talk to you later.
I wanted to see the rest.
What does that mean?
Class was interesting.
Glad to hear it.
I feel like I know you.
I've had this feeling we've met before.
Oh my gosh, wait, second round is different.
I feel the same way.
Yep, I'm certain.
We've met somewhere.
Either in this life or another.
I guess I'll see you tomorrow.
She remembers, she remembers.
Day 2.
How was your second day?
Is everything as you dream about?
Or as you dreamt about?
You are as I... Wait, you are as I dream you.
Nothing seems real.
I'll see you tomorrow.
I'm not feeling so well.
Oh no, our girlfriend.
Austin, welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Hey, do you live down this road too?
No, I'm just following.
I know you do.
Yes, the second house on the left.
Wait, isn't that her house?
What if I say that?
What?
What do you mean?
I want to live inside you.
What's the matter?
I'm scaring her.
Day 3.
Come on, talk to me.
How can you be like this?
What's wrong with you?
Talk to me.
I thought we were having fun.
Are you sleeping?
Are you listening?
Can you hear me?
You are so beautiful, Flirt.
Now we can be together.
Talk to me, Goose.
Do you really think this is real?
Oh no.
Guys, we are back at this.
I turned it down a little bit.
Do you think I can...
Do you think if I left now, it would be fine?
Let's see.
I think I have to...
Okay.
Alright, let's try it one more time.
Day 1.
You must be the new trailhead.
Gosh Ume, your voice is just grating.
There are a lot of cute girls here.
Don't worry, it's sure to get better.
My name is Ume Ito.
Okay, talk to you later.
Alright, let's see.
Have you started liking school?
I wanted to see the rest.
What does that mean?
Go back to Europe?
Do you want to know how to get the different ending?
It's kind of specific.
Yeah, actually if you don't mind.
I sort of feel like I know you.
Do I have to like not be evil and weird?
Oh, like you wanted to see more of the school.
Do I have to not be a freaky guy?
Do not follow her home this time.
Get the default ending a few times.
When the strange dialogues pop up, be creepy to the max.
You need to decline walking her to the street.
Walking her street on this playthrough.
Oh, okay.
I don't know.
Yep, I'm certain.
We met somewhere.
Okay, so we are not walking her home.
How was your second day?
Is everything you dreamt about?
Everything is a dream.
Hey, would you like to walk to my street with me?
It's not very far.
No, I'm tired.
There we go.
Okay, maybe another time then.
I did it!
Day three.
It's such a pretty day today.
Don't you think?
It surely is.
It's a good day to be alive.
It's strange.
Okay, so now do I be a freak?
Wait, on your third playthrough you can't walk with her and then the next playthrough you go full freak phantom.
Oh, not until loop four.
Okay, so I act normal.
I just feel like today will be a good day.
The flies.
Oh no.
I can't wait.
Yes, I will.
Alright, talk to you after class.
Alright, we are normal.
We are normal.
Class is kind of strange today.
The teacher seems really focused on germs and gas pressure.
How have you been?
Are you still feeling tired?
I feel incomplete.
I feel longing.
I feel worms in my skin.
I can never escape the worms, man.
First Eternal Darkness.
Now this game.
Everything is worms.
Real Higurashi moment.
I feel longing.
Oh well, I'll see you tomorrow.
I'm not feeling well.
Day four.
Oh no, she's not normal.
Hey, are you feeling alright?
What if this isn't a dream?
What's wrong?
Don't...I'm being a freak!
Your eyes!
OK Alright guys, I think we can...
I'm seeing if she says anything different.
OK, now I'm a freak, right?
I think you picked the wrong option.
Wait, I didn't mean to let the freak take over.
Oh no!
Wait, how was I supposed to know?
All of them were freaky!
All of them were freaky.
Oh I did it right?
OK.
Thank you guys.
Alright, last time we play.
Day one.
Alright, now I'm a full freak.
I'm a new kid.
Slipping.
Dripping.
Don't worry, it's going to get better.
Liar?
Instead of the school bell it says liar.
That's the bell.
I gotta go.
How do you start liking the school?
My eyes are dissolving.
Glad to hear it.
I just kept dying over and over.
I will consume you.
It wasn't all bad.
After a while I learned how to enjoy myself here.
See you tomorrow.
OK.
Day two.
How was your second day?
Have things gotten better yet?
Everything is disgusting here.
Well, OK.
Anyway, today is a new day.
Full of new experiences.
The flies can't fit anymore.
What does that mean?
Death bell?
Oh no.
Oh gosh.
Scariest stories.
Try not to be scared.
I was at school and the bell rung.
But what I didn't realize was...
It was the death bell.
Class was at least interesting today.
I had no idea how many perfect spirals existed in nature.
I've no... Wait, what do I do here?
Which one is the most freaky?
Maybe it's the flirting.
The flirt?
I feel like it's the flirt or the last one.
I can't tell.
Flirting is pretty weird.
True.
Number three.
OK.
I'll see you tomorrow.
Oh, why is she blushing?
I'm not feeling so well.
Was she like that the whole time or am I crazy?
Oh!
Classmate Ume Ito has reported you for your behavior.
You have been transferred from Sunshine Academy and Ume has escaped.
Game over.
Love failed.
I got an achievement.
Love is over.
Oh my god!
Elris.
A game.
Is that it?
Sorry, I got really caught up in that, you guys.
Is there nothing else in here though?
Oh, no.
Play Sunshine Academy.
OK.
So we have to watch out for a baby in here.
We can escape from there.
Oh, wait.
This isn't a loop.
Oh, it's just a little bit maze-y.
Oh, there is something in there.
Never mind.
How about this way?
Yeah, Tokimeki Memorial is different.
Shiori Fujisaki, my beloved.
OK.
Oh my gosh, you guys.
I'm gonna get lost in here, actually.
I'm gonna...huh?
Oh, we made it to the beginning, but...
Uh...
It's the matter, baby.
What's the matter, baby?
I think he comes from these parts of the walls, right?
Oh my god.
The shade upon my heart has been exercised.
Such a spectacular evening.
I've never seen a vision as heart-stopping as yourself.
Oh my gosh, Brian.
The Riz.
OK.
So let's try again the same way that I did before.
I went this way.
And this was where the baby was, I think.
Let's run past the baby.
Oh, great.
Love that.
The baby is stuck in the wall, so we can run this way.
Something is glowing down there.
Guys, what is that?
What's glowing down there?
What is it?
I'm just walking.
OK.
I don't think I'm...
I don't think it's getting closer.
OK.
Oh, wait.
I think it is getting closer.
I actually can't tell.
It's not a dead pixel.
It moves.
No, it's definitely getting bigger.
It's definitely getting bigger.
It's definitely getting bigger because it's bigger on my OBS.
Undead pixel.
Is it a ghost?
Oh, wait.
I think it has arms.
It looks like arms that are outstretched.
Wait a second.
Maybe I shouldn't be...
Oh, I think I'm making...
Don't
get up before Saturday!
But it's Friday.
Oh, man.
So...
In that hallway we don't...
go...
there.
I guess.
I don't know what to do down here.
At least I got the achievement for the...
I zoomed in on my iPad to see and gave myself a heart attack.
I'm sorry.
It came zooming as soon as I realized it was coming close to us.
It's a trap.
Oh, this is baby.
That's right.
Alright.
Okay, so we're just gonna have to not get lost in here.
I thought this was supposed to be way faster.
This DLC.
How much more do I have to go?
Hmm.
To the left.
Take it back now, y'all.
Oh, shoot.
It's the baby.
Oh!
Oh my gosh!
Finally, the isolation ward!
That's why I just couldn't find the tank.
Oh gosh.
Oh!
I think we need to get out of here somehow.
I think we need to find our way out.
Oh gosh.
I'm scared.
Ouch!
Oh gosh.
I can't run anymore.
Go!
I made it.
Holy moly, I made it.
Oh my goodness.
Holy moly.
Oh, my health recovered too.
Perfect.
Alright, to the isolation ward which was where that guy was.
Okay.
Wait, where was the isolation ward?
Oh no, it was in the basement, right?
In the morgue?
There was the morgue and then there was the isolation.
It was in the basement, I remember.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
What a thrill.
I also...
I thought I had to like click on that instead of just walk to it.
You know, kind of like how these doors say open.
Save!
We did it.
To the basement.
Oh gosh.
I wonder what the dollhouse is going to be like in the next DLC.
Okay.
Do you want an honest answer?
Maybe.
I don't want to rush it either though.
I have fun exploring and stuff too.
Nurse Tanaka, report number 407.
It wasn't me.
I swear it wasn't.
It may have been my body and my hands, but I know it wasn't me.
Oh, sorry.
Hold on.
What's this music?
Is it another guy or is it ambiance?
I can't tell.
Locked.
Okay.
Like I can't tell if it's another demon or monster roaming the hallways, you know.
That's a lot of blood.
Nurse Tanaka, number 408.
I found out how to stop them.
You can see... Oh, you see they are in my head and can control me for a time.
Good night, Mint.
I'll catch the rest in the VOD.
Good night, Cryo-sai!
Thanks for hanging out.
But if I keep using the radiology machine to douse my head with radiation, they go away for a while.
Radiation machine.
What happened in here?
Nothing good.
Everybody's got the same scoliosis problem.
Wait.
Which way did I come from?
This way?
What's wrong with this room?
Why did the music stop?
OK, this room is special.
Wait, I'm getting lost, you guys.
Oh gosh.
OK, I think I'm going this way.
Oh, a note.
No!
I went the wrong way!
Oh my god.
Wait.
I went the wrong way!
It was litera...
Oh.
It was just a single door.
Oh, is this a maze?
No!
Read the first letters?
OK.
Spooky maze.
This is so...It feels very...
Like now it feels very Silent Hill 3.
Oh shit!
No!
Not the eyeball monster.
Oh gosh.
Is this a dead end?
No.
This is a dead end.
Shoot.
Oh, a door!
We did it.
Thank goodness.
It's a new place.
Oh, we got the exit key!
This place should be shut down.
You should go now is what this achievement is called.
It's broken.
What's this?
I'm so sorry my little angel.
I tried hating the man that took you from us, but in the end the only person I can hate is myself.
You always like to scare people, especially when they didn't understand something.
I was confounded.
No one understood your costume.
But I guess people don't read Poe anymore.
Even with the new Price film.
That man clearly overreacted to your fireworks.
But we can only blame a PTSD sufferer so much.
So she goes to the glass?
I've been here so long, I've forgotten so much.
Wait, what's in there?
There's someone in there.
This place needs to be shut down.
She's saying that.
I'll do my best.
I'll do my best to shut it down.
Exit was...
By the save.
I hear that.
There's definitely something here.
There's definitely a monster, I think, making that music box noise.
I think it was the end of...
Yeah, the maze is gone.
Thank goodness, right?
Okay, so it was the end of this hallway.
I think.
Yeah!
I think the...
I think the smoke has definitely gotten worse.
We made it!
Spooky, I did it!
Why are you so quiet?
Yeah!
Her voice is so quiet.
I can't run anymore.
That's it.
You win!
Was that the calamari hospital?
Yeah!
Alright guys.
New game.
Spooky's Dollhouse.
Let's go!
Let's just go right into it, baby.
I wonder if it's going to be similar to this one.
It was just kind of like more exploration than going through...
the hallways, you know?
The air here is heavy with must and mold.
Oh wait, you are on Steve's struggle.
What the hell?
I have a hand.
Wait, what did it say?
What?
Your spirit has been recorded.
I
didn't get to finish reading it.
The wallpaper is a choice.
It looks like angry... wait.
Oh those are eyeballs.
I thought it was a mouth.
Oh my gosh, actually it's kind of awesome.
I too wish cats and owls would comfort me when I cry.
You can't heal in this one?
Is that what you guys are saying?
You picked up a map.
To use it, look down and interact.
Ok, we are in the...
What the hell is that?
What about Pies?
Pies is so...
Today I got to, not cuddle with her, but I got to pet her a lot.
She's not like a skittish cat where she runs away when you pet her.
But she's very much like, I want to be pet on my own terms.
The creator made another game called Lunacid.
If you want to check it out, it's like a dungeon crawler.
Very good game.
Thank you.
Congratulations, GL Labs Associate.
You have been volunteered for our Proud Parent Program.
You have been given a doll and your duty is to train the soul entrapped within.
To confine it to the doll, you must keep it in good spirits and give it attention.
Many of the beta candidates were children when they died and will likely attach themselves to you without problems.
But there may be times when punishment or extraction of spirit energy is necessary.
The energy can feel quite replenishing, but please refrain from abuse as it negatively affects the ghost.
In the event of husk rejection or injury, GL Labs is not responsible under any circumstance.
Is this my doll?
Something about this doll draws you to it.
Not yet.
But what about this doll?
I see.
Oops, my bad.
It's locked.
I could tell, but...
Wait, so I can only save once?
That doesn't seem great.
Doll acquired.
I guess we get the doll.
Wow!
Any spirits want this doll?
Why is there a timer?
Where am I?
I can't see.
The doll is in the way.
What was that?
Lots of noises happening.
Okay,
any...
Any ghosts?
It's locked, okay.
Any ghosts wanting a doll to inhabit?
I'm not really quite sure what this entails, I'll be honest.
I'm a little confused.
Can you rotate and crop so the doll has your head?
No!
That's weird.
Everything here is a choice.
Oh, so we're in this long hallway.
I think we're about to go into a mystery room.
Okay.
There's a ghost on screen right now!
Oh, protect the doll.
Geolab ID 1863.
Log 23.
We've made progress, but none of it has been ideal.
You guys hear the footsteps?
Norco!
Welcome to the membership!
Thank you!
We developed a system to summon and contain these spirits.
However, we've yet to find a suitable container.
When the director first summoned his daughter back from the dead, we were astonished, but she didn't stay here long.
Without something proper to tether the spirits back to the earth, they simply fade away.
We tried simple jars.
See, guys?
Jars don't work for ghosts.
See?
We tried simple jars, vases, and the like at first, but...
Sorry.
These containers limited the functions of the spirits.
We've had minor success using humanoid vessels, but the spirits are still tied to the physical damage of the containers and are thus too fragile.
Okay.
Oh, gosh.
My hand scared me.
Little doll.
What do you think of that?
Oh, my gosh.
Croaky.
What do you like?
Music?
It sounds out of tune.
I picked up the West Wing Key.
Let's go.
Where is that?
I wish I could tell, but my doll is just...
She literally takes up the whole space.
Are these spaces in the carpet?
Oh, God.
This one right here looks like a dog.
You know when people are like muffin or dog?
Muffin or chihuahua?
That's what I see.
Okay, wait.
I don't know where the West Wing is.
We are still exploring.
Oh, God.
Oh, God!
What the hell are you?
Oh, my God.
I'm running away from whatever the hell that was.
Can I put my doll down?
I can't do anything with her.
What was that?
What is that?
I was a good girl all day long.
But when dad got home, he was all wrong.
So I hid in my room until he was gone.
And then I shot him in the face at 545.
His gun was so...
Oh, my gosh.
It's 544 right now for me.
That's insane.
His gun was so shiny, sparkly and neat.
And his face was so mushy, gushy, squishy.
I wanted to shoot more people, but my mom made me sleepy.
Now I'm in this weird house with all these weird white coat people and they won't give me a gun.
What is that sound?
Is she gonna shoot me?
Because it's 545?
Wait, do you think it changes in the note?
Depending on what time it is.
Look up.
Oh,
my God.
It's a little freaky.
You don't want the bear?
See, it's 545.
I guess I could put her back down.
Look at her.
She sits so politely.
It's locked from the other side.
Now I can see what my map is.
Okay, what is S?
We went to the piano room.
We didn't make it to the garden because of...
Because of the babies.
Oh, save, you think?
I unlocked it.
I don't want to leave my doll for too long.
Okay, hold on.
I'm trying to get a feel of the place real quick.
So we went down through there.
I wish I could... I'm using my eye.
I wish I could use my cursor.
Okay, so that goes into the west.
The root cellar is circled for some reason.
Down there was the office, and then we went to the piano room.
Did we go into the clock room?
I don't think so.
I don't know why I need to carry you, but...
Okay, so what was in here?
Never mind.
This is the clicky girl room.
Okay, so we don't need to go in there.
Okay, this was the clock room.
Aha!
Yes, we did go.
It's just... It's locked.
We can't get the...
The... What are the...
The garden sheet or the nail pliers, whatever.
Okay, those are where the babies are.
I want to go see the garden though.
Bull... Wire cutters!
Yeah, bolt cutters.
Can I kill the babies?
Oh my gosh, it's reading my real time.
I just noticed.
Oh yeah, I guess...
If I had stayed in there with the doll, I wonder if she would have killed me.
She would have shot me.
Little babies!
Yeah, take that!
Take that!
Oh, they melt.
Nasty.
Nasty little creatures.
Okay!
Come on doll.
I protected you.
It's reading my actual time.
That's so freaky!
Come on!
I killed you.
I unlocked it.
I don't know what's in here.
Oh, now we have a shortcut.
Nice.
And this is the garden?
This door is wrapped tightly.
Try to open it.
Ouch, ouch, ouch!
I should have known that was going to happen.
I think we need the bolt cutters.
You should try again.
Hey, get out of here!
Ganging up on me.
Doll, I think we need to go to the west wing.
Screw these little guys.
I don't care about them.
We are going this way.
The west wing.
Bed?
Can you guys hear the music okay?
I feel like it's kind of quiet.
Let me know.
I think you can shake the doll to heal.
Oh my gosh!
Oh my gosh, shaking it baby!
Let's turn it up to like 50.
Oh god!
Shake, shake, shake your baby!
Remember the note said not to do that.
What?
Shake my baby?
Are you sure?
Good spirits, give it attention.
Many of the...
How do you feel?
Please refrain from abuse.
This is abuse!
Sorry ghost.
Sorry.
I'm so sorry.
I'm so sorry little ghost.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry!
I pressed the wrong button.
Okay, so try not to get hurt.
Oh my gosh, they are everywhere!
Ouch!
Please, I'm just trying to explore!
What the?
GL labs.
Emergency containment door.
Set her down.
They can't come in.
I'll be back for you.
I don't fit in this.
I can't stretch or else I break.
They did this to me.
Uh oh.
But if you stretch you break.
Or husks.
These are all filled with husks.
Doll 3.0.
Husks, husks, husks.
What is it?
Holy moly!
I think we are okay.
I don't even know what I picked up.
I kind of want to see it though.
Let's just chill in there.
Hey baby!
Oh clock winding key.
Thank you.
Stupid!
It looks like he's giving me the finger as he walks away.
Hey, don't be so rude you know.
Yeah, you just flipped me off for real.
It's not my fault that they made you ugly.
Don't need to be rude about it.
Oh come on, come on.
Don't be so rude.
This guy is camping.
I can hear him right there.
Happy Spooktober!
Spooktober!
I knew immediately to just leave.
So I think we can go.
I mean you were mocking him.
Oh there is a hole here.
What is that?
What is that sound?
What's that?
I don't see anything in there.
It sounds like the guy I locked up though.
Oh gosh.
There is a hole.
Reach inside?
Something grasped my hand.
Uh oh.
Guys?
Gosh dang it.
Access card required.
Oh my god!
And now this guy is around!
Okay, I'm so sorry.
I have to shake you a little baby.
Remember to heal, but my baby will get mad.
I thought we were fine.
We locked him in there.
Gotta get to the tea room.
Oh yeah, I see it.
Okay, so that's the root cellar.
The garden has two extra doors that lead to nowhere.
That's kind of interesting.
Okay, he's kind of camping.
He kind of like is really scary.
But, oh my gosh.
Nice!
Nice, we gamed.
Oh, what's this?
Let's have some tea!
Let's get to know your doll!
No.
What are we doing?
Wait, maybe get up.
Hold on.
I'm going to read this note.
The tea room for proud parent volunteers.
Instructions manual.
Okay, maybe we should have read this first.
Can everybody outside please stop interrupting me and my baby's time?
This is our bonding time.
This room functions to relieve stress and replenish spirit energy in the event that the doll has lost potency.
You may use this function by placing the doll upon the pedestal and sitting across from it.
In the event of husk rejection or injury, GL Labs is not responsible under any circumstance.
Good luck, proud parent!
Guys, I'm a parent!
Oh, my bad.
Are you feeling better, baby?
I think he's feeling better.
We're replenishing the baby.
Everything is calm and nice, except the guy outside the door.
He sounds horrible, but you know.
It's so quiet in here.
Oh my gosh, it's so relaxing in here.
Okay, the guy is actually starting to leave, so...
Good job, baby!
Wait, is he?
No!
I need to go that way, please!
Head over this way!
Go to the other...
Go to the other part of the hallway, please!
I thought he was leaving.
Oh, there he is.
He's right in front of the door?
I think he's camping.
Oh, my God.
Is this what Batara does for you?
Oh, shit.
Wrong place.
Actually, that ended up working out.
Nice.
The west wing is... Oh, hi Spooky!
Yeah, I'm here!
Nice save.
Okay, so I think I'm going to have to leave her here.
While I go get the thing.
Perhaps.
I don't know if I can hold her and this at the same time.
Oh, uh... Unlocked it.
Oh.
Oh, oh!
Uh... Wait.
Was it... It's not the 5.45 time, right?
Oh, it was!
Picked up the bolt cutters.
Okay, let's go get our baby.
Hey, baby.
Okay.
That was over here.
Use the bolt cutters?
Yes!
And welcome to the... Oh, the garden is...
Not quite what I expected.
Batara sits with you at the table to recharge.
Oh, no.
Batara takes my energy.
She does not recharge my energy.
Monika.
1929-1968.
Beloved by all.
My dear Monika.
Although it was difficult, I respected your wishes and let you rest.
I miss you every day.
I miss you so much.
I'm still going to try to save our daughter.
I know it's not what you wanted, but I've already gone too far.
I'm so close.
I just have to find a way to keep her here.
I love you.
I hear something crawling about.
Something crawling about in here.
Locked.
Let's try this door.
Great hall.
Oh, my bad.
Where the heck are we?
Did the doll's face change?
I don't think so.
Oh, what is that?
Oh, sorry.
I'm kind of blocking the doll's face, huh?
We can put me on.
I'll make myself like right here, maybe.
There you go.
Sorry, the game is not like full screen or anything either, but...
Chill music.
There you go.
Now you can see a little bit more, but what the heck is this?
Because I know you guys are probably like dying to see what this doll looks like.
Why do you do that?
Electric barrier.
Yeah.
It feels like a set up.
Cloud?
Wait, what?
What do you mean by that?
I don't like the looks of those.
Wait, where is this anyway?
Sorry, I keep trying to look at the map, but instead I'm opening the door.
I don't want it to activate.
Oh, we are in this bottom hallway.
Okay, so there's two rooms down here.
I guess we should try and check them out, I guess.
Is this like a... These look like hiding spots, don't they?
Go to Mint's bedroom.
What was that?
Oh, I think that just fell.
There's footsteps.
A doll is a timeless thing.
In shape of a human, but created perfect.
Immortal and unmoving, yet hollow, devoid of soul.
A fitting symbol and possibly a usable device for our goals here.
Soon I will have you back, my dear, but first I must make sure it won't constrict you.
They're kinda cute.
Yeah, they're pretty cute, I think.
The little dolls here.
Yeah, they're pretty cute.
Did this thing move or... No, it didn't.
Okay.
Next room.
Oh boy, as soon as I grab that... What is this?
Oh, there are several broken doll parts and a pair of plastic clasped hands that appear to be holding something.
They are slightly melted together.
Pick it up.
If I have to.
Picked up some doll hands.
Yeah.
I don't know what that was.
Look at this.
What is it holding?
Wait, okay.
How would we open these hands up though?
Hmm.
How would we open these hands up?
The hands go somewhere, yeah.
We haven't gone down this way yet.
I think that's the clown room, if I remember.
Oh my god.
Feralit, you scared me.
I heard... I heard the voice and it sounded like...
It sounded like... Like a whisper.
Raiders!
Oh, thanks for the raid!
Who raided me?
I didn't see.
Sorry.
Oh, Chiyo!
Chiyo, thanks for the raid!
Hello everybody.
Welcome back.
Good morning, master.
My name is Midfrantum.
I'm playing the DLC for Spooky Jobscare Mansion.
And... It's fun!
This is quite spooky though.
Quite spooky.
Oh, we're almost to a furnace.
Oh my gosh.
Murphy, thanks for the 20!
Wait, someone else gifted.
Paperbacks, thanks for the 5!
Caseraptor, thanks for the 5 gifted!
Thank you guys.
Welcome, welcome.
Oh no.
No!
Ok, let's go to the clown room first.
I don't know if I want to deal with this yet.
Oh, wrong forever.
Thank you for the 5 gifted.
Wait, what's this one first?
There's just children everywhere.
Little babies and stuff everywhere.
We can't place anything there.
I don't like the idea of the clown room.
You think I like the idea of the clown room?
GL Labs ID 54.
Log 67.
I haven't told anyone yet, but I think this place is haunted.
There are like these strange...
Moaning or woaming?
Not the strange woaming.
Oh, they really meant woaming.
Sounds at all times.
Like a moan, but also like woah, you know?
So, woaming.
And there was this painting that I kept staring at, but I think it was changing.
Is this it?
The baby?
Baby?
I'm also keeping this girl in my sights.
The woaming.
So it's like a moan, but a woah.
Alright, clown room time everybody.
Oh, get your face paint out.
Hold on, before I do this...
Before I do this...
I would like to go save.
I would like to save.
Actually, will it let me?
I wonder.
Okay, good.
Alright.
Oh, the bolt cutters.
It's just a clown.
I'm not really afraid of clowns.
So, you know, this room will probably be the least scary ever.
Oh god!
Geolabs ID...
1863.
Yeah, he's just chilling.
Log 34.
To keep the dolls happy we created this party room.
We even summoned a spirit to entertain them.
But this experiment has failed miserably.
The dolls hate it here.
And seemed totally freaked out around the clown.
I requested the document on how it was found.
And apparently they tried to summon a happy human ghost.
But instead got something else.
Oh my doll!
Oh my god!
No!
She's scared!
It looks human, it acts human.
But just to be safe we installed a cage.
What did they summon?
Oh my god, he's kinda got a booty though.
Okay doll, I know you're scared.
We'll get out of here.
He said it back!
He's laughing!
He's laughing in there!
Oh my god!
Uh...
Okay, we were going to the furnace area.
Go back?
Go back in?
Why were you talking to me?
Oh, it's kinda freaky in there.
Okay.
Oh, he's still laughing!
Oh, it's later, okay.
Alright.
Alright doll, be a good doll, okay?
I'll try not to get killed.
What is in here?
A mystery.
I hear like some scuttling.
Oh gosh.
The furnace should be great.
We can burn everything, you know?
Here we go!
Open the furnace?
Oh, my bad.
I think I'm stupid, you guys.
Put the plastic doll hands in.
Oh yeah!
Close the furnace.
Okay.
Open the furnace.
The doll hands have melted away revealing a small key.
Time to go.
I don't know what was out.
I don't know what was in there.
I don't know what was in there, but...
We got a key.
Doll, I'm sorry.
Okay.
You think he's still laughing in there?
Wait, it gave me two keys?
The key might go to the cage?
No, I was thinking...
What doll?
Wait, what are you talking about?
I thought it would electric shock them.
Thanks, Spooky!
I was trying to get...I thought it was to the other...
Okay, hold on.
No.
No, sir.
Wait, she's not closing her eyes anymore.
His eyes are really mesmerizing.
I was thinking it was to this.
I hear him laughing!
See?
I knew it.
I knew it, I knew it.
Thanks for the super chat, Mike...
Sorry, hold on.
You're not Mike Tyson's ass.
But you're eating it for sure.
Now we have a weeping angel clown.
This sucks.
This sucks, this sucks.
So all the dolls...
I didn't realize all the dolls turned into those little piles, but why?
I was wondering what these were.
What else haven't we done?
I can't see anything.
I think we've done everything in this area.
Besides, once we get to the root cellar.
Let's go in here.
We're in the labs!
Generic lab labs.
That's what the GL stands for?
It's generic lab?
What the hell?
Just another Thursday.
This is messed up.
Doug.
So Doug was an associate.
And then they turned him into a video game.
Let's play Doug.
Good luck.
I'm Doug.
There's ghosts chasing after me.
What am I supposed to find?
That's a rock.
Doug, I'm not quite sure what the point...
Am I supposed to shoot the ghosts?
Get ready man.
Go Doug!
I killed it.
OK.
I guess you can shoot the ghosts in this game.
It's kind of fun.
Down!
Did it say get ready stinky?
I just released this ghost, but that's OK.
Yay!
Get ready victim.
Sometimes I press down and it goes...
And instead it goes...
It goes like to the right.
Oh my gosh.
That was a close one you guys.
What if GL Labs made Yuri instead of Haunted Dolls?
Missed opportunity reel.
I think these rocks can kill me if I dig into them on accident.
Alright, come after me.
Stupid ghost.
No!
Mortis.
Rip in piece.
The memory of Doug.
Sorry Doug.
I failed you.
Mortis.
OK.
Based on a true story Doug.
What's in here?
Oh no.
Is it bad when I'm...
Is it bad when I'm more afraid of the...
Of the big room than the blood stain?
Green ghost jumpscare in the bottom right.
GL Labs ID 54 log 809.
Hopefully now that the doll project is over I'll get transferred back to the surface facility soon.
It's been very interesting, but I generally fear for my life every day.
That's not ideal job security.
Wait, is there more to this?
I don't want to die, please.
OK, I'm just...
Where are we?
Escape tram.
Oh no.
Actually, I can't see because of my doll.
Live, laugh, love.
I can't read these.
They're stuck in the table.
There we go.
GL Labs ID 1863 log 32.
We abandoned the doll idea of tethering the subject to a physical object and instead we sealed her spirit within the mansion itself.
Her abilities within the facility should be incredible.
The director would be pleased with the outcome of his sacrifice.
They sacrificed... Wait, is that the guy who was trying to bring...
His daughter back and then they sacrificed him?
Why does this look like it can become an electric field?
Did you see this?
I just noticed.
This looks like it can turn on an electric...
This looks important.
Let's go to the non-important one first.
Are they talking about Spooky?
Probably, right?
Because...
She seems young and she's controlling all of this.
Access card required.
There was another thing that needed an access card.
I think it was...
Oh, this is the escape tram!
Is it train?
No, it says tram for sure.
Oh, come on.
Ok, hold on.
Actually, yes.
And then, I look.
Spirit seal.
Hell gate source?
Cool.
There are three doors here.
Someone farted down there and probably smells bad.
Ok, we came from this direction, so...
Let's try over here.
Why did I set you down?
Oh, this is the hell gate source, I think.
Yeah, it might be scary in there.
Never mind.
Ok.
Oh, whoops.
Sorry.
Guys, I get so turned around sometimes in this game.
I don't know why.
Alright, let's go to the spirit seal.
Whatever that could be...
Oh, come on!
Ok, we have to go to the area.
We have to go to here.
Goodbye my beloved doll.
I'll see you when I come back.
I'm in the cellar.
Oh, I'm in the cellar.
No map of this area.
Oh, it's really hard to see.
Oh, it's really foggy.
What's this?
It's a black candle.
Ok.
Oh, what's this?
A way out?
Ok, I'll take that.
Never mind.
Oh, come on!
Need an access card for everything.
Door is broken.
I don't want to get so lost in there.
My doll!
What do you think that is?
It's some sort of strange...that's a sculpture?
Oh, I see it.
So if the girl is haunting the mansion, she came up with that.
She's a little freaky.
It needs a...
It needs a lollipop.
I can't see anything.
I don't even know where I came from.
Here?
No...
Log 187 ID 1210 These spirits get so temperamental.
We keep having to perform rituals to keep them in check.
When they act out, it's necessary to inflict pressure on the husk inhibited by the spirit.
Don't forget that these dolls are not real people, but that's...
But they're real people's spirits.
Is that not the case?
That's like saying I'm not a real person.
I mean, I'm not a person.
But I'm real.
I think we didn't go this way before.
Oh.
What a waste of paper.
ID 1210
Waste of paper.
Oh gosh.
Oh golly.
What is this?
That's weird.
Okay.
I came from this way.
I don't like this guys.
I don't like this.
I don't like this!
What are these?
Another black candle.
Okay.
Am I gonna have to find all of these and light them or something?
Because that would be torturous.
What?
A life-sized doll hangs here by severed silver hooks.
Oh sorry.
Several silver hooks.
There is a metal pinwheel piece glued to them.
The pinwheel!
I don't know how to get out of here.
I think it was this way.
I think I see a light.
Get me out of here.
Wrong way.
This way?
Was it this way?
I can't remember where that one door was.
Oh gosh.
It was this way.
The lollipop door.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It was down here.
Insert the lollipop.
Oh it's different.
Yeah, the map doesn't work so...
Okay.
It doesn't even look like it will work if we combine it with something.
It looks completely different.
Okay.
You can look at the shape of it guys.
They even face different directions.
But like, this has like little pokies in the middle of it.
And this one is like smooth in the middle.
It's completely different.
Do I have to go back in there?
There was also another hallway.
Sorry, I'm so lost in here.
I wish I could just turn the brightness, the fog down.
Just a tiny bit.
Wait, this way maybe.
No?
I'm so lost.
It won't move.
Broken.
Was it this one?
This is where we came from.
I'm almost positive.
Yeah.
We didn't really look around anywhere else in this room.
I just kind of booked it.
I was scared.
Okay, there is nothing else in here though.
I think we...
need to go back to...
where the girl is, maybe.
This is the access card, yeah.
This looks like it's taken so much inspo.
This one, the two DLCs look like they take so much inspo from...
Okay, this is where the girl is.
So I want to go in this one.
But from Silent Hill...
Okay, then what's this door lead to?
Gosh guys, this is so confusing.
Okay, we're here.
This is not the room with the freaky...
No, this is the temperamental ghost.
Let's go back to...
If I can find it.
Oh here, okay.
Let's go back to where the ghost...
I say the ghost, the girl.
Okay.
I don't think we really finished walking around in here.
Because I found that and then I ran away.
This was another box thing, yeah.
Okay.
Oh, maybe I did.
I'll get you down from there, queen.
Her hair is glitching a little bit.
It's breezy.
Guys, does anyone know a hint?
Does anyone have any hints to spare?
I'm so lost.
It doesn't help that I'm lost last, but I'm also lost in the brain.
Maybe I haven't been down here.
There are some spooky sounds coming from here.
A heavy metal plate over a narrow hole.
It looks like it can slide shut.
Okay.
Metal...
We got the pinwheel piece.
Okay, nice.
So now it looks way more like the...
Like the actual thing that we need.
But do we need a stick?
Do we need a stick?
Get me out of here.
This way.
No.
I guess we'll go try anyway.
Okay.
We need a stick.
What other...Besides the candles?
Besides the candles?
I'm not quite sure what we can do.
I wish I could save the game.
Is this a lighter?
Lighter?
The keycard.
Yeah.
Black candle.
There is no note.
I think it was through here.
And then...here.
Okay.
Did we maybe...get out?
And then I can maybe go save.
Oh my gosh.
I think it's the little children.
The little babies.
Little babies!
No more little babies please.
Save.
SAVE!
Oh my gosh, we gotta go get my baby.
She's probably so angry.
Wait, how do I get my baby?
Baby, where...
Baby, where are you?
Baby is in the garden.
Okay, we can go this way.
Oh!
The door is being held shut by little hands.
Who was holding it?
My baby!
Baby?
Wrong door, baby.
Baby, you can hear me!
I'm right here for you!
What's that?
My baby!
What's in here?
Why are you covering your eyes, baby?
Are you scared?
Baby!
Let's go relax, baby.
Let's go relax.
I think she's scared.
I think we need to go to the tea room.
I think we need to...Oh, goodness, baby.
I think we need to go to the tea room and relax.
Relax.
Don't worry, baby.
Oh, no, baby.
Uh, baby?
Okay, baby.
I said don't worry, baby, but actually, worry, baby.
That's the matter, baby.
I think if we just bolt past it, maybe we'll be okay.
Oh, my God.
We juked!
Are you better, baby?
It was red, this little meter.
Oh, it's going to go back to 100.
Oh, my baby is so sad.
My baby was at 0!
Actually, baby, I might shake you so I can have full HP.
Is that okay?
I didn't abandon her.
I almost died, okay?
I think I'm more traumatized than...Actually, how did baby get into that other room anyway?
Did baby go search for me?
This room would be way more relaxing if we didn't have a horrible slithering in our ear.
Oh, baby.
Okay, you're okay though, right?
Yeah, sit down.
And I sit down.
Your meter's at 100.
Yeah, we're good.
Alright.
The root cellar we were able to go into.
I don't think...
there were any other rooms in this area that required card keys.
If I...
remember correctly.
This is what ASMR sounds like to people who don't like ASMR.
True.
Oh, my goodness.
I was so close.
Holy moly.
Okay.
This baby is not our baby.
This baby sucks.
Have we ever tried just leaving?
Oh, I can't go back.
Okay.
Alright, let's go back to the labs.
Let's go back to the lab.
There was nothing else, right?
Uh-oh, my chat disconnected.
Hmm.
Oh wait, this area had the clown room.
We can go to the tram now.
Yeah, we can go to the tram.
True, true.
You guys said to go to the clown room again, right?
Hmm.
What were in those two bottom rooms?
Ah, no doors that needed a...
that needed an access code.
Maybe we're fine.
Alright, baby.
But before...
Oh.
I keep going to the wrong one.
Okay, this is the girl.
We don't need to be back in here.
This one needed an access.
Or no.
We are... somewhere.
I can't tell anymore.
Oh, you saw I skipped.
Kind of pointless to go back.
Oh, was I supposed to go back in and he was going to be escaped and be like, woah, scary.
Wait, where is the room that...
Huh?
Am I...
Where is the room that I fell down into?
This is the doll.
Huh?
What?
Oh, wait, it was in here, wasn't it?
Oh, that's right, that's right.
It was like this one, I think.
I think.
Hold on, let's check this out.
Beep beep.
Can we actually just leave?
Can we like just get out of here?
This train looks like it goes all the way back to the surface.
Start the train?
Not yet, I think.
You sure?
I didn't complete in here.
Ok, this is the area that was wigging me out.
I couldn't figure out where I was at.
Ok, ok, ok.
No!
Oh, I can't go back.
What's in those rooms then?
You already saved, so start it.
I guess that's true.
If I set her down here, does it still open up?
Nope.
Hmm.
This was the...
Hell gate source.
Exciting!
Oh my gosh.
No.
Are you kidding me?
No, no!
No!
Kira Genesis.
Not enough ritual materials in the room.
You mean this whole thing is run off of a Sega Genesis?
I have to go back and get the candles.
Baby, I'm so angry baby.
But I'm not gonna take my anger out on you baby.
I'm so angry.
I'm so mad!
No!
What was this one?
Oh, this was the spirit seal.
Seal chamber.
The seal can be turned off.
But if I do this, I'll have to let the dottled spirit go.
There's no going back after this.
End the nightmare.
Wait, I can just...
Wait, what does this say first?
The seal is almost complete.
And then you can return to me.
It requires a nightmare to work, so I will surrender mine.
The same nightmare that took you from us will now bring you back.
Do I need all the candles before I do this?
I wonder.
Oh baby.
Okay, so we can...
I did save.
I don't know... Okay, so once I...
Do I have to go into the hell source room to see the candles before I can go back and pick them up?
Because if I can just run back and pick them up now...
Or like, you know, once I die...
Yeah, we're at an ending crossroad for real.
I guess we have to go into the basement again.
Alright.
Alright guys.
But I can just end the nightmare and all these little assholes will shut the hell up.
All of them will shut up.
You got this, Minto?
Thank you!
Alright.
I don't like it down there.
Okay, we know one was where we fell into the place.
We know one was by the spooky girl's body.
I don't remember where the third... Oh, the third one is...
In through that door that we unlocked to get the...
To get the keycard.
We're going in, Mint.
I feel like we have to.
Right?
To get the good ending?
We must brace ourselves.
Is this like, no choo-choo ending?
Guys, I feel like I'm gonna die so many times.
Is it really difficult down there?
If you've played this before, do you know?
If it's really difficult down there with her?
So we could take the tram and leave, use the seal and end the nightmare, or play Sonic 3 and Knuckles.
Decisions.
If this ends up being the wrong answer, at least we can save to...
You can save to go back to the right one.
True.
It's spooky.
I could tell you, but that would not be fun.
Why don't you guys ever... What happened to backseaters?
Back in my day... Look at them, trailing along the walls.
Back in my day, backseaters always wanted a backseat.
Back in my day, backseaters would tell you everything about a game.
Now they're like, no help.
Why?
Even if I ask for a hint, that's not help.
That's just a hint.
It's just a little... It's just a...
It's just a little...
Oh it's...
Oh gosh...
I have to go to the little ghosties room.
We didn't give help unless you explicitly ask.
What are you talking about?
I say, can I please have a hint, please?
And people say, no help.
I think that's you not helping.
Actually, before we go in, I'm going to go to the little ghosties room.
BRB.
I'll be fast.
BRB, BRB.
BRB.
Did anything spooky happen?
Chat, do we help Mint use the little ghosties room?
No.
I can do that all on my own.
Nothing spooky.
OK.
Let's do this!
Put on your game face!
Alright.
I know where they are.
It's just a matter of getting them.
OK.
Oh gosh.
Golly.
It's just a matter of getting there.
What if we get one, come back, save.
Get two...
I can hear her outside the door.
I can hear her out there.
What if we... What if we get one, come back here, save.
Oh man.
Oh, she's scared.
I am too.
Oh, she's not scared anymore.
Alright, one candle, get two.
I can get all three probably.
But I feel safer grabbing one, saving, coming back.
It's gonna take so long.
It's gonna take so...Coward!
Have confidence?
OK.
She doesn't do that much damage, doesn't it?
I just don't know where the other two are.
You guys, I get lost.
I get lost.
That's my biggest issue.
That one was the easiest one.
I don't know.
Just remember the right path.
I remember once I find the room how to get to the other candle.
Oh gosh.
OK.
Hey, that wasn't there before.
Did I go to the wrong place?
No.
Yes, I did.
Yeah, I did.
Wait, no.
Wait, yeah.
Yeah, I did.
Wait, no.
Wait, yeah.
Yeah, I did.
Refusal to help is a big compliment.
Backstabbing often arises from frustration.
Oh my god, she's scared.
So am I.
She's scared and so...
Oh shit.
I didn't know she'll come through the walls!
Guys, my stamina...
Oh my god.
Dodge and run.
Oh shit, wrong way.
Oh my god.
That's a locked door.
OK, how do I get home?
I went the wrong way.
I need a break!
OK, I just have to find the...
Shake baby.
OK, I just need to find the...
The pinwheel door.
OK.
2 out of 3.
Is it?
OK.
When I go in here...
Am I seeing a model clip through the door?
I don't think so.
I think that's like a blue filter.
A blue foggy filter.
Is it?
Oh my gosh.
Boo!
Mazoku!
Thanks for 3 bonds!
OK.
I must...
I don't know if I go in.
If I go to the left or go straight or go where?
All I know is I must go!
I must go somewhere!
I think it's this one.
Oh my God.
Lady.
I found it!
She's scared and so am I.
I know.
My little baby.
Don't worry.
I'll get us out of here baby!
I'm running!
What the?
Wait!
What are you talking about?
This game is horrid!
Oh my God.
Oh,
it's just the little babies.
OK.
Nevermind, I can handle these.
This game is so horrid.
I swear to God.
OK.
Oh my gosh.
My
baby!
My baby is smiling.
She's really happy.
Did I just hear a piano go boop?
Did I just hear one piano little boop?
OK.
I feel like I should put down the candles first.
I'm gonna set you down right there baby.
He's scared.
OK.
Any further spirit returns will result in system collapse.
What does that mean?
What?
Choose a monster.
What do you want?
String bean?
Broccoli?
Or act like the most stereotypical demon you've ever seen.
Wait.
Puppet.
Oh no!
I remember these guys, but the puppet I think was the easiest to deal with.
Wait, so am I summoning him?
Which do you want?
None of them.
The beep is the most annoying.
Wait, so why am I doing this?
Why am I summoning a guy and then just unsummon him?
The dear spoopy mansion would I miss?
Meep!
Thanks for the ping!
Oh, because if I summon this guy it will be a system overload so they won't be able to summon anything else.
I don't remember what was the deer's issue.
I just remember I got the axe from him.
If anything, let's summon this guy.
And if I hate it, I can always reload.
Spirit already active.
Lead back to hell gate.
Sourced to return.
This door is sealed during the ritual.
What do you mean it's sealed during the ritual?
Turn off the ritual!
No!
Just turn it off!
He's so loud.
I know I'm turning it down.
Just turn it off!
Oh, I think I have to kill him.
He got me though.
Ouch!
Hello?
Get him in the circle?
Ouch!
How do I just get him in the circle?
Oh gosh guys, I think I'm going to die here for real.
He's in the circle?
Oh, this way!
Oh my gosh, what was that?
Ouch!
Oh shoot!
Oh my gosh guys, this is not good.
I wasted too much time in that one room.
This is not good.
I wasted too much time.
Remember the strat?
What's the strat?
Oh gosh guys, I'm going to die.
I
wasted too much time.
I'm an idiot.
Oh my gosh.
Not yet.
It's not over yet.
What am I even doing with this whole plot?
Oh wait.
Sorry, I went the wrong way.
Guys, I have to survive this guy.
He's kind of cracked.
He's kind of insane.
Can I?
So I can't bring her though, I'm guessing.
It doesn't seem like... Oh I can't because I need the axe.
Oh, I don't need the axe.
I don't know actually.
Before we try again, how about trying the tram first?
Oh ok.
I guess I don't need the axe.
Alright doll, let's just leave.
Let's just get the hell out of here.
Bye everybody!
Oh my gosh, it's just like a Disney ride.
Where do you want to sit doll?
My little baby, let's sit right here.
Relaxing.
Are we going to see a skelly?
I sure hope not.
I don't want to stand too close to the glass.
What happened?
This is supposed to go to the surface.
What could have happened?
It's locked.
I'm scared!
Ashes to ashes.
Bones to squeeze.
Your corpse will slowly turn to cheese.
That was... anticlimactic.
You missed the red skeleton.
Oh well.
That was kind of lame.
It ain't easy being cheesy.
Yeah, so true.
Oh gosh guys.
I guess I don't need my axe.
I feel comfortable with it.
You know?
And my axe.
Which one is the deer?
What does the deer one do again?
Makes the screen all staticky.
That's it?
I just have to run?
Wait, what was that?
What did it say?
Doll's spirit interference.
Place outside room.
No!
That's why.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry my little baby.
I'll be back.
I'm going to hell!
OK.
Akira Genesis.
So, I just run with the deer?
I can't remember.
I can't remember how it was at all.
Make sure they don't go through walls.
It's a bit different this time.
Move super fast through the walls.
Oh, wait.
Wait.
Is he the one that I just kind of like inch back?
No.
There was one that was just like I had to like... No, that one was like an eyeball kind of thing.
I don't know which one would be easiest.
Yeah, he would talk to me.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm not picking the beef.
That one would hide doors.
You guys, that would make this thing impossible.
I can't have that.
I can't.
He will hide the doors.
It will make it impossible.
You guys only remember the beef.
You don't remember the frustration of him making the doors disappear!
Yeah, I do have beef with him.
I guess I'll try the deer.
Lead back to hell gate.
Source to return.
Oh my
god.
Oh my god.
I just found a dead end and the deer are coming after me.
The flashing lights are so bad.
I think the puppet was easier.
Is this a dead end?
Oh my god.
Just kill me.
And the deer.
Where is the door?
Join us.
Please let the door be over here.
Please let there be a door here.
Oh my gosh guys.
My children.
Where is the door?
Oh here.
Oh my gosh.
One HP and a dream.
Join us.
Is this a loop?
Or is it actually going to end?
Your submission is inevitable.
I think I have to not run so much because then it will go through the walls.
Why do you run, child?
Please!
Ok, let's go this way.
I found a door.
Come, come, come.
I'm going through the same doors over and over again.
I can't tell if...
Oh my gosh.
Come back!
By a freaking deer!
I couldn't avoid him!
There is no way!
That was so...
That was so cheap.
But I think maybe he...
When I got the hang of it...
I think it was ok.
Revenge for shooting the deer in faith.
Didn't I have my revenge?
The revenge was had.
You can axe the deers.
We'll axe the deers.
No, no beef.
You guys, I can't even find the doors normally.
I can't even find the doors normally.
Finding the doors with the beef will be impossible.
You guys are really trying to kill me.
I'm not listening to you.
Let's go.
Well, I...
Oh, it didn't kill me.
It's kind of fast.
I feel like I was so close too.
I feel like I was so close.
Oh,
I'm getting hit.
I'm getting hurt.
Oucha!
Join us.
I know I can axe the deer, but I gotta get close.
See, it still hurt me in the end.
Kind of lame.
My children.
What about my baby?
What about my child?
I'm also a parent.
Please don't let this be a dead end.
Please.
Please, God.
Where's the door?
Okay.
Oh, shoot!
No!
Oh my God.
Now it's actually 1 HP and a drink.
This is the worst.
This is actually the worst.
Oh, this is it.
Guys, this is it.
Wait, what's happening?
What's happening?
I've never seen this before.
Oh, hello!
Ah!
Deer is the hardest one?
Really?
Everyone said that the beef was the hardest.
Beef?
Okay.
So the beef is gonna...
The beef is gonna...
Make the doors disappear, right?
What else does he do?
He just runs at me, right?
He doesn't go through walls at least, but...
Just makes doors invisible.
How will I find the doors though, you guys?
I'm never gonna make it out of here.
He does go through walls?
He can still go through the walls, what's the point?
Maybe the puppet would be easiest.
But there were all these other little ghosties that were showing up with the puppet.
It was scaring me.
Oh gosh.
Might as well try.
What if I first try it?
That would be crazy.
Oh shit.
Oh my god, no way.
I'm back in the... Goddamn!
No way.
I'm back in the goddamn pizzeria.
Oh gosh.
Beef!
Wait, this might be...
Oh my gosh.
Where is he?
OK.
If the hallways aren't so complicated, it might be OK.
Like this, you know?
Like I can tell, obviously.
But the other hallways would have been impossible.
Oh my gosh, all the beef everywhere.
You think it's here?
Oh my gosh.
The beef.
I hear him.
Oh my gosh, please.
Please.
I hear him.
Oh my god.
I love when it appears back.
Like, oh, by the way...
Oh my god, he's right behind me, isn't he?
OK.
How much more, you guys?
How much more?
How much more of this hell?
Please!
Oh my god.
Is it here?
Yes!
Oh my god.
Game!
Game, please!
Oh my god.
Please be it.
I found it.
One hit though.
Whatever.
One hit.
This is it.
Oh my god.
Please be the end.
Upstairs?
Oh my god.
And then downstairs.
What?
No way.
No way!
No, please!
I can't!
Exit!
Oh my god.
No!
What the hell is this?
Near death experience.
Almost got you.
Oh my god, I actually did first try the beef!
I first tried the beef.
Save?
Oh yeah, true.
Wait, no.
We are just about to end the game, right?
I guess I should save though.
I'll save.
Oh my gosh.
Guys...
We...
Game...
Ok, let's go put this to rest.
Maybe, I guess.
And then we can leave.
So we seal?
We seal?
I survived the beef.
That crawling area was absolute hellish.
You can't run through there, so you are just crawling and he is just kicking your ass while you do it.
Should have checked the other ending first.
What?
I don't know what other ending there is.
Wait, I don't understand.
Wait, what do you mean the other ending?
One guide to save.
What?
There was multiple people saying to save.
You know guys, it's fine.
It's ok if we don't get every ending.
Don't worry.
It's ok.
The other ending was releasing the nightmare without closing the hell gate.
Oh well, I'm way too late of that.
I already did the hell gate.
Whatever.
Goodbye baby.
My baby.
Oh my god, probably the bitrate is going insane right now.
Goodbye baby!
It was a nightmare.
Oh my gosh, my eyes.
The night I saw the devil.
Oh.
What the hell is that?
What's yelling?
Oh my god.
What the heck is this?
Oh ok.
Can I get more bullets?
Bullets.
Oh ok, I reload.
Nice.
Where?
These flashing lights are kind of crazy.
I'm so sorry guys.
The ping?
What do you mean the ping?
I can't believe there's more.
Ok.
Follow where the ghost guys come from I guess.
Oh my gosh!
Why do you guys keep saying ping?
It really is doom now, huh?
Oh no!
Am I ok?
I can't see anything game!
Everything is red!
Oh ok.
We recover.
Perfect.
Ok.
Funny ping gun.
Oh it makes a ping noise.
I guess it dies.
1, 2, 3, 4.
1, 2.
Hold on.
There we go.
Tactical reload.
And that's why we tactical reload everybody.
What is this?
Is this the new...
Gosh, you can do so much in Jeezy Doom, huh?
Is this the hallway to go down?
Seems like it could be.
Spooky?
Oh spooky!
Oh no!
I shot her!
I mean not me, but spooky!
The PTSD is what they were talking about.
I didn't shoot her!
I didn't do it!
And so then they put spooky into the building.
They had her possess it.
Someone is sleeping here.
Plant the gun on them.
I just framed some guy?
I can't lose you.
Oh my gosh!
I will bring you back.
This is so FNAF.
JPEG DOCTOR!
Amazing.
Mission complete.
I always wanted to tell you how that night really ended.
But I couldn't.
Because you were gone.
I need your forgiveness.
That's why I wanted you back at any cost.
But in the end I robbed you of both life and un-life.
Please go on and be with Monika.
I'm sorry.
So if we run around now there is no ghost and stuff?
Nevermind.
No...
Oh gosh!
OK, nevermind!
Time to leave!
What the hell are you?
Oh gosh!
Time to go!
What was that?
Are we going to make it out in time?
Everything is turning white.
Did we do it?
We got rid of the mansion!
Bye Spirits!
Wait, does that include me?
Good ending!
I couldn't read the rest.
Sorry.
Yay!
The nightmare is finally over.
We did it!
I completed Spooky's Jump Scare Mansion.
Look at the art, so cute.
Oh Spooky, happy birthday!
Spooky eating sushi, I think.
There is definitely a bottle of soy sauce.
Oh my gosh, Nurse Spooky.
Cute.
Little baby Spooky.
Nice Spooky!
Spooky with a machine gun!
Fix it Spooky.
Oh no!
Spooky with Kyubey!
What?
Everything on fire Spooky!
I got a knife Spooky.
Sketchy Spooky.
We did it guys!
We did it!
Let's go!
Spooky's Jump Scare Mansion.
Finish!
Sorry I couldn't get the other ending where I did it without closing the hell gate.
But, whatever.
You can always... I'll YouTube it.
And you can too, if you want to see that ending.
Yeah, just YouTube.
There is two other endings?
Wait, what's the other ending?
What do you do for the other ending?
I'm already YouTubing it.
Endless has new specimen.
I did see that they like... I guess... What was the last update?
2023 sometime.
I saw that they added some little guys to Endless.
The first ending is not doing the nightmare.
The second ending is leaving without sealing.
Not doing the nightmare.
There is one more ending in the new game plus of Katamari.
Hospital if you kill your own ghost in the sea.
You can do that!
Wait, did I have an axe?
I guess I did.
Great job with those spooky DLC.
You were brave today.
I was brave!
And now I'm hungry!
I'm going to go have dinner.
Who do I possess today?
I don't know.
Who's having a delicious scrumptious dinner tonight that I can possess?
And eat your food.
Who's hungry for Minto to eat it?
My dinner sucked tonight.
You already ate it.
Come on guys, think of Minto before you eat.
If you ever think...
I think this is going to be a delicious meal.
I don't mind if I don't have it.
I don't mind if I don't taste it.
But Minto would probably love this.
And you should just let me possess your body.
Eat your food and be on my merry way.
Okay, beef for dinner.
Actually, maybe I will get a burger.
Chai Princess, thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
I can't believe I beefed in my first try.
I was like, I was so against the beef.
Thanks for the stream.
Thanks Salty!
I can't believe I beefed in my first try.
Hold on, I can't stand this song.
Wait, there was another song.
Well, whatever.
I'm here now.
The deer is more stylish.
I think the deer is probably the most difficult one.
Since you have all of the deer as enemies as well.
Oh my god!
Thank you!
It's okay, it was my birthday yesterday.
Congrats on good ending.
Happy late birthday, I'm sorry!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday, dear Abed!
Happy birthday!
Thanks for the spooky stream.
By the way, SlayThePrincess just got a big update yesterday with new endings and 3 new princesses!
Might have to try it.
I really like SlayThePrincess.
More girls.
More princess.
That was a good game.
You know what I was also... I was thinking about playing it next week.
But I was also like... I don't know, I've played it before.
But I kind of just wanted to play it for me.
But I was thinking of next week maybe doing Little Misfortune.
Do you guys know that game, Little Misfortune?
Have you guys ever seen it?
I wanted to maybe try and get the...
There's like a good, good ending.
Yes, little lady?
Yikes forever.
I feel like I've heard of it.
It's so good.
Think it's okay to replay it?
Would it be okay, I wonder?
It's kind of... It's Halloween.
It's a little spooky.
Never seen it, wow gee.
Really?
Fancy.
It is a goofy but depressing game, it's true.
I'll think about it.
I think I have it on my schedule currently, but if I think of another game...
Because it's technically currently my last spooky game that I have.
I think for our spooky month.
Next week I want to do like all spooky games.
Since we're...
Oh yeah, because I have...
Maybe...
So I have Monday I was going to do Faith.
And then Tuesday I wasn't going to stream.
Then Wednesday I was going to do Little Misfortune.
Then Thursday is my re-debut.
But then by then October is over.
So, yeah.
I mean I guess I could still stream on Tuesday.
But I think I need that day to prep for my re-debut.
Just one last prep day.
I think.
Not that I won't do spooky games obviously after...
Halloween, but...
Just a little bit of a break.
Yeah.
We'll see.
Will you play the Silent Hill 2 remake?
I'm not sure yet.
I like Silent Hill.
I played Silent Hill 2.
Um...
But it was a long time ago.
I remember Silent Hill 3 more than I remember Silent Hill 2.
So...
I don't know.
I've seen all the great reviews about it and everything.
So I do still want to play it.
But I don't know if I want to stream it.
I did hear one criticism about it.
That it was like...
A little bit more action-y than...
Than the previous game or the original was.
And that like...
There's more mannequins kind of everywhere.
And that just...
It feels like...
Oh my gosh.
IGN released this like...
Best 10 horror games of all time.
And obviously it's IGN.
So it's like...
Take it with a grain of salt.
Part of it is probably Rage Bait.
But...
Oh my gosh.
One thing they put on there.
Before I even was finished going through it.
I was like Silent Hill 2 is going to be at the top of the list.
I know it's going to be number one.
Is it all Resident Evil?
Almost.
Oh my gosh.
Well actually they did like a fan version.
That was like fans get to vote for their favorite horror games.
And it was like top 50 fan rated horror games.
And probably like 25 out of 50 of them were Resident Evil games.
And I'm like guys...
Have you ever played another horror game before ever in your life?
Please.
But...
Alien Isolation was on the list for the most part.
The list wasn't so bad actually.
I know some people...
I think it was Leah...
No, Ashton.
I think Ashton was like clouding on the fact that they put Five Nights at Freddy's over Resident Evil 1.
But...
I don't know.
I mean Resident Evil 1...
But one thing I totally disagree with is having Outlast on the list.
Outlast is scary for the first 30 minutes.
And then it becomes a repetitive nothingness.
You just run around.
Oh, guys chasing after you.
Run, hide.
Okay.
Run, run.
Oh, run, shut a door.
Okay, you're safe.
So...
Two, thank you.
A wild red fox just tried to follow me into my apartment because it wanted my pizza.
Are you Little Misfortune?
What's the best horror game, Minto?
I'm biased though.
I'm actually biased.
Because there was also no Fatal Frame on there.
And I'm like, Fatal Frame is...
So scary.
Benjamin...
You personally hate Freddy's?
I...
I actually... I do like Five Nights at Freddy's.
I hate what the series has become.
But I think the first Five Nights at Freddy's game...
Is a really great horror game.
I stand by that.
I think it has...
You know, I love the way that they build the mystery.
And that it's kind of...
You know, not thrown in your face.
You're not going around reading little notes.
Like, it's all very subtle.
And I...
You know, you can't doubt...
You can't...
You can't ignore how influential it's been.
It's mostly audio logs.
No, no.
It's actually, like, little posters on the back.
And, like, in the...
When you're looking at the monitors.
Like, you'll see...
You'll be, like, looking at the monitors.
Trying to wonder where Freddy is.
And you'll see a poster that's like...
Missing children.
Stuff like that.
It's actually...
I just love subtle horror like that.
It's like some of my favorite stuff.
But...
Another thing that was on there.
On the list was...
Slender, the eight pages.
Which also is like...
I guess I would put it on there.
Not as, like, a great horror game.
But as, again, as influential as it was.
I don't know.
I guess you kind of have to wonder...
It's, like, hard to, you know...
Do you rank them by how good of a scary game they are?
Or do you rank them by how, you know...
How much they influence the horror genre.
Cultural milestone.
Yeah, it is a classic.
And back then, everybody was losing their minds over it.
They were like...
Yeah, a product of it's time.
It's like the perfect way to describe it.
Yeah.
A product of it's time.
It was like, oh my gosh.
The horror game.
It was...
I don't want to say it was revolutionary.
But it was like...
The gameplay kind of sucks.
I don't want to say it sucks.
It's simple.
It's, you run around and you grab eight pages.
And Slenderman is chasing after you.
That's about it.
Stepping stone.
Another thing that was on the list was PT.
And I'm just like...
Can you really put a...
A non-game.
I mean, of course it's a game.
But can you put a thing that...
Wasn't...
It was just a teaser.
It was a demo.
But again.
It like influenced so many horror games to follow.
Everything...
For like a good solid two years after.
Was just hallway simulators.
Repeating hallways.
Hallways after hallways after hallways after hallways.
But I also, I love PT.
So again, I'm biased.
I don't know.
I love PT.
I love the talk.
Oh my gosh.
I got a TikTok yesterday.
That was like someone covered a sock in barbecue sauce.
And like put it on their hand and put it in a sink.
And they were like, this is the talking baby in PT.
This is what...
Good stuff.
Oh my gosh.
Sherry, thanks for the 20 gifted.
And Quacky, welcome to Mabu Sherry.
I try to...
As much as I dislike IGN.
The list, I could for the most part...
For the most part give them benefit of the doubt on some of the answers.
But obviously people are gonna disagree on some things and be like, no.
Resident Evil 7 was the best horror game ever made.
And nothing will change my mind.
Or whatever.
Game reporters.
Am I right?
It's all subjective after all.
Yeah, pretty much.
They also put Dead by Daylight and Left 4 Dead on there.
Yeah.
I was very much questioning Left 4 Dead.
I was like...
Zombies does not equal a horror game.
But there are some spooky parts in Left 4 Dead.
But does spooky parts mean...
It's a spooky game, right?
Like this is action, action, action.
It's not horror at all.
Except when you anger the witch, I guess.
Minecraft is horror now.
Oh my gosh, there was a new update, wasn't it?
Or there's going to be a new update with like...
Another scary thing in the mines or something?
Why?
Why do they keep putting the scariest shit in Minecraft?
Less spooky zombie game.
Yeah, they're like...
Zombies, obviously that means it's of the horror variety.
Amnesia?
Amnesia was on the list.
And I think Soma was also on the list.
Was Dead Space... Dead Space was on the list.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Dead Space was on the list.
So for the most part, that's what I'm saying.
I can understand it.
I don't agree with all of it.
But I understand it.
Soma is good.
I actually was going to play it this month.
But I...
I don't know why I didn't.
It's... I think it's because it's like more not my type of horror.
Like it's... Isn't it?
It's like...
How do I describe it?
Action but horror-y.
When is Minto's spooky game topless?
Nobody... Everybody would get mad at me.
Everybody would get mad at me.
Was Fear on the list?
No, it wasn't.
The greatest sheer terror is when you're in Minecraft.
Hours deep in a build and you hear a creeper noise.
So true.
You get chased a few times but the real horror is the existential dread.
I don't know.
I can get mad at you for not sharing.
If that helps.
Yeah, so...
I don't... I have never played Amnesia before either.
But it's also really not my type of game.
I think of the water level and I just wanna throw up.
I watched a friend play it.
I remember going to a friend's house.
And they owned it and they played it.
And I'd be like...
Wow, I don't wanna play this ever.
Thanks for the fun stream.
Hope we can see some Minto Fatal Frame in the future.
Otsumita.
Thanks, Rikki.
Yeah, I would love to do Fatal Frame.
Maybe Fatal Frame 2.
Fatal Frame 2 with maybe like...
It's not a CRT game.
But it's a game that definitely looks best when it's not in HD.
You know what I mean?
When the ghosts have that fuzz about them.
That like make them super duper...
Super duper...
Almost like this could be real spirit photography.
Run it through a filter.
Yeah, I think I will.
I have some filters I could use.
Some Nautica.
Oh my god, some Nautica.
If you're afraid of fish, yeah.
Alright guys, I'm gonna get going.
Thank you so much for hanging out with me.
And have a good night.
And I'm gonna go get...
Oh shoot, oh my gosh.
I just realized the time it was.
Oh my god!
Okay, I got stuff to do.
So, actually...
Hold on.
I wonder...
One second, real quick.
Oh, here we go.
Oh yeah.
Okay, nevermind.
Okay, anyways.
Hikamio!
Welcome to my membership.
Thank you!
Alright.
Otsumita everybody!
Thank you.
Thanks for the super chat.
Otsumita!
Bye-bye.
Otsumita, Otsumita, Otsumita!
See you later.
Bye-bye!